well can i ask you about the craziest
one
which is uh the one we know
maybe least about which is consciousness
is it possible that there are certain
kinds of matter would be able to
classify
as um conscious meaning
like the so there's uh the pan cyclists
right with the philosophers who kind of
try to imply that all matter has some
degree of consciousness and yeah you can
almost construct like a physics of
consciousness
yes do you um
again we're in such early days of this
but nevertheless it seems useful to talk
about is
is there some sense from a physical
perspective to make sense of
consciousness
again consciousness is uh
imprecise a very imprecise word and
loaded with
uh connotations that i think we should
we
don't want to start a scientific
analysis with that i don't think
it's often been important in science to
start with simple cases
and work up uh consciousness
i think what most people think of when
you talk about consciousness is okay
i'm what am i doing in the in the world
this is my experience i have a rich
experience rich inner life and
experience of and
where is that in the equations and i
think that's a great question a great
great question and actually i think
i'm gearing up to spend part of the i
mean
to try to address that in coming years
one version of asking that question just
as you said now
is what is the simplest yeah formulation
of
that to study i think i think i'm much
more comfortable with the idea of
studying self-awareness
as opposed to consciousness because that
that sort of gets rid of the mystical
aura of the thing and self-awareness
is uh in simple you know the
i think uh contiguous at least
with ideas about feedback so
if you have a system that looks at its
own state
and responds to it that's a kind of
self-awareness
and more sophisticated versions could be
like
in information processing things
computers that look into their own
internal state and do something about it
and i think that could also be done in
neural nets this is
called recurrent neural nets which are
hard to understand and kind of a
frontier
that they uh uh so i think understanding
those and gradually building up a kind
of
uh profound
ability to un to
conceptualize different levels of
self-awareness what do you have to not
know
and what you have to know and when do
you know that you don't know it or when
do you
what do you think you know that you
don't really know the the the these
uh i think uh
clarifying those issues when we clarify
those issues and get a rich theory
around self-awareness i think
the that will illuminate
the questions about consciousness in a
way that you know scratching your chin
and talking about
qualia and blah blah blah blah is never
going to do
well i also have a different approach to
the whole thing so there's uh from a
robotics perspective you can
engineer things that exhibit yes
qualities of consciousness without
understanding
well well the how things work
and from that perspective you uh
it's like a back door like enter through
the psychology door
precisely the car's inside yeah i think
we're on the same wavelength here i
think that
and let me just add one comment which is
uh i think we should try to understand
consciousness as we experience it
uh in in as
in evolutionary terms and ask ourselves
why why does it happen this thing seems
useful
why is it useful why is it useful
i think we've got a conscious eye watch
here interesting quest thank you siri
okay
get back i'll get back to you later
um and i think what we're gonna i i'm
morally certain that what's gonna emerge
from analyzing
recurrent neural nets and uh
robotic design and advanced computer
design
is that having this kind of
looking at the internal state
in a structured way that
that doesn't look at everything as guys
has encapsulated looks at highly
processed information and very selective
and makes
choices without knowing how they're made
they said they'll also be an unconscious
i think that that is going to be turn
out to be
really essential to doing efficient
information processing
and that's why it evolved
because it's it's it's it's helpful in
uh
because brains come at a high cost
yeah there has to be there has to be
good why and there's a reason
yeah they're rare in evolution uh
you and uh big brains are rare in
evolution and they
they come at a big cost you mean if you
you they
they they have high metabolic
demands uh they require
you know very active lifestyle
warm-bloodedness
uh and and take take away from the
ability to support metabolism of
digestion and so it's it's
uh it comes at a high cost it has to it
has to pay back
yeah i think it has a lot of value in
social interaction so i
actually i'm spending the rest of the
day today in uh
with our friends uh
that are our legged friends in robotic
form at boston dynamics
and i think so
my probably biggest passion is human
robot interaction
and it seems that consciousness from the
perspective of the robot is very useful
to improve the human robot interaction
experience
uh the first the display of
consciousness but then to me there's a
gray area between the display of
consciousness and consciousness itself
if you think of consciousness from an
evolutionary perspective
it seems like a useful tool in human
communication so yes
um it's certainly well whatever
consciousness is will turn out to be
i think uh addressing it through its
use yes and working up from simple cases
and also
working up from engineering experience
in trying to do efficient computation
including
efficient management of social
interactions
is going to really shed light on these
questions as i said in a way that
sort of musing abstractly about
consciousness never would
you